the crossovers crossover crossover
especially the really fun one offs where
we get to see like just like Diggle turn
up for the King shark stuff or you know
I thought you just so you Diggle turn up
do you have any lined up that you can
announce right now uh yeah so - we're
gonna have a little Felicity on the show
and what can you tell us will she be
doing
she and barrier is giving advice yeah
yeah just giving advice our hundredth
episode is 508 turns out 508 will be
chapter two of our three-part crossover
so the hundredth episode is going to be
the middle part of the cross over and
then Episode nine is our mid-season
finale so we're we're kind of designing
things to be like a hundred - episode
hundredth episode celebration the
bigness of our mega crossover and the
bigness of our mid-season family so it's
actually times kind of perfectly flash
paradox will have something to do with
some of diggle's reality if you follow
what's happened on lash he made some
changes to a timeline it will affect
Diggle to some degree yes it affects his
family in a very very personal way
there's a lot going on with Diggle this
season and yes it affects his family
some of the fun is seeing those
crossovers and and seeing these
characters interact with the other shows
so mark and Phil can you tease are we
gonna be seeing some familiar faces this
season I mean within the first frames
yeah I mean it right out of the gate we
we're blending these worlds so you're
not gonna have to wait long just wait to
use the bathroom till at least the first
commercial break well who are we gonna
sing mark no we're gonna see mr. Amell
playing Oliver Queen
yeah yeah right from the very beginning
actually mayor Oliver Queen so now go to
you this time around
no we're slowly moving in that direction
all right anyone else anyone else were
gonna be seeing this year well I think
we might have caught a little glimpse
there in that sizzle reel of uh yeah
McDonough playing mr. damian darhk--
he's gonna return for our season
premiere he's you know he's you know
we've got 122 years for us to play with
so we're gonna meet him in 1942 that's
why he's looking so dapper in that in
that trailer so Brandon you've been on
arrow the flash legends David you have
been on arrow and the flash any chance
that we might see you at some point
showing up on legends yeah it's kind of
like in this in the Berlanti universe is
like we're all are kind of connected and
is there's so much intersection right so
yeah you know I'm looking forward to
being on Supergirl I don't know if
Diggle will be on Supergirl but I'm
looking forward to that because wrong
what's wrong with my show your show is
awesome but uh I'm looking forward to
the reaction yeah Diggle we'll have when
you see Supergirl oh yeah yeah
definitely if you're gonna have a team
of superheroes you got to fight a team
of super villains so we're gonna start
off with Matt Lesher reprising his role
as eobard thawne the reverse-flash
so you also saw in our teaser trailer
that neal mcdonough is back as damian
darhk-- everybody who watched episode 15
knows that Leonard snart is dead but
everyone who watched episodes 1 through
16 knows that it's a time-travel show so
that means we can bring back Wentworth
Miller as Captain Cold
and there's one more and I'm totally
forgetting who it is yeah I need some
help I maybe could he come out and tell
me I've had a little bit of experience
with time travel
so I expect I'll I'll fit in just fine
Malcolm Merlyn I know I speak for the
fans when I say that we miss Katie
Cassidy all the time she is incredible
what are the chances we may see her
again
well we will definitely see her in 501
and our premiere of the season and we
have made a deal with her across arrow
flash and Legend so Katie Cassidy is
definitely not gone from this universe
nice
you